and welcome back so we now have
leaderboards in our game and we have
this lovely view all of my leaderboards
controller however it would be awfully
nice if while I were in the middle of
playing a game or done with the game I
could still also see the high scores
that were available in that particular
level you know just so I know what score
I have to beat or so on and so we can do
that with our leaderboard controller
unlike the leaderboards controller with
an S the leaderboard controller lets you
immediately bring up the scores for a
specific leaderboard so this is pretty
easy to do let's jump into my game view
controller and let's look at our little
nib file here and I'm going to add a
button let's put it down here at the
bottom and we'll call it leaderboards I
guess leaderboard with an exclamation
point because we're super excited about
this leaderboard and we'll anchor it to
the bottom here OOP done and I'm going
to bring up my helper view control or my
helper editor it's going to automatic
and in our game view controller mm-maybe
here we will add a view leaderboard
button was pressed actually there we go
so let's go into our game view
controller here and we'll add of this
thing so first thing I'm going to do is
we're going to create a leaderboard
controller leaderboard VC equals gpg
leaderboard control or alloc init with
leaderboard ID and huh I don't actually
know what our leaderboard ideas because
we've gone ahead and abstracted it away
in my leaderboard manager class so maybe
what I'll do is
is a let me go ahead and create a little
class method here that will return in n
a string which will be leaderboard ID
for difficulty level and will pass in
our difficulty level simple enough and I
think actually implementing this is also
pretty straightforward basically going
to return and maybe we'll just cast this
just to make sure leaderboard IDs level
and you know wouldn't kill me down to
moraine valves checking here but I'm not
going to because this is a sample app so
let's go back to our game view
controller and let's create a little and
a string leaderboard ID equals I'm going
to go up here and import our gmn
leaderboard manager all right now let's
go back down here and now we can create
our end a string that's our leaderboard
ID and that will equal gmn leaderboard
manager leaderboard aya for difficulty
level self game diff and now we can
basically say our leaderboard VC is our
leaderboard controller alloc init with
leaderboard ID leaderboard ID
leaderboard vc leaderboard delegate will
be self and then we can call self
present view controller our leaderboard
vc animated yes completion handler nil
we're going to get a little warning
because we haven't declared herself as a
GP g leaderboard delegate so let's do
that i'll go up here and we'll do it
right here remember this is leaderboard
controller delegate not leaderboards
controller delegate
and now we can add a delegate method
leaderboard view controller did finish
self dismiss the view controller
animated yes completion ill and we're
done so now I can run this and maybe I
can jump into my easy game here and hmm
thinking maybe before I start playing
this game let's see what the leaderboard
says and I can look and say oh look this
this guy Todd here he's got an all-time
scorer of three no way I can beat that
so maybe I'll go back and check out my
medium game here if I view the
leaderboard remember we're creating a
leaderboard controller with the
leaderboard ID of our medium leaderboard
so will directly bring up the scores for
this medium leaderboard that's great and
then I say well I guess let's just check
out the hard game and here my
leaderboard I've got no scores yet and
so maybe I as a player now say well this
is clearly the game want to play because
I'll get the top high score or whatever
so there you go we now have learned how
to submit a score to a leaderboard we've
learned how to bring up the leaderboards
controller which displays all
leaderboards within a game and we've now
seen how to bring up individual
leaderboards which would be very useful
if at the end of a level say you want to
show players what the top scorer were
for that level so there you go that's
about everything you need to start
adding some leaderboards into your game
no my sequel database required really no
database required on your part we do all
that database work so you know go ahead
and start adding these to your games and
remember the best part is all this stuff
works on both iOS and Android so if i
had my cross platform version of guess
my number people could be competing
against all their friends no matter what
kind of phone they owned which is pretty
awesome so there you go in the next
lesson we're going to start taking a
look at cloud save this I think is one
of the most powerful features that we
provide it's just a very simple pretty
straightforward used cloud save solution
that again works cross-platform so you
know your Android players can save their
state no matter what their device are on
your iOS players can
save their state no matter what device
they're on and even if you were to have
an android phone and an iOS tablet you'd
be able to save your game across both of
those platforms which i think is pretty
awesome so we'll start taking a look at
that in the next lesson stay tuned
haha